i think we should talk about alex jones
now we got this story from the daily
mail that was a really brilliant segue
back yeah i thought so too oh i just i
just figured it was like it was not a
segue at all it was perfect it's a
beautiful stage january 6 house
committee prepares to subpoena alex
jones emails and texts for any contact
with donald trump after his legal team
mistakenly sent them to sandy hook
parents lawyers
okay i'm just so frustrated i don't know
if you guys were watching the uh the
court case with um
the alex jones trial no not yet it's
just this is made up stuff
so here's what happens
the the plaintiff's attorney he's like
we've got all of your text messages
because they sent it to us by accident
and alex was like
i gave my cell phone to you i gave
myself into my lawyers to turn over and
they're like you tried to hide it and he
was like
i gave my cell phone to you you have it
and they're like no you gave it to us on
accident and he's like what
this is the craziest thing that they're
saying
definitively that it was mistakenly sent
to them
when you have two factions arguing one
side saying it was one side saying it
wasn't why would you just decide one
side is telling the truth this is the
craziest thing to me also isn't it part
of discovery like doesn't it go to
everybody well so that was the issue
they were arguing that it wasn't sent
during discovery
that it was like not sent during the
typical process or whatever and i'm just
like okay well why would that have been
an accident if they sent them all of his
text messages or something like that
also what is this accent they were just
like i put in the wrong email address i
mean that seems like a strange
coincidence i accidentally gave you this
dropbox link something yeah i
accidentally specifically gave you the
thing that you wanted right yeah i don't
get it and then the judge the judge like
intervened and said
to uh to the jury
to that
we don't know
that it was like he was trying to hide
it or something but we do know they
received it in not in an improper way or
something sounds like they're they're
doubling
two issues right now they're doubling
the issue of alex and what he said about
sandy hook with this dumb this trump
january sixth thing yeah like what's he
on trial for sandy hook has nothing to
do with the trump has nothing to do with
he's on trial for one reason they're
trying to destroy him his career his
life and everything freaking it's a
clown show they've been going on for
like seven years this is insane he
already admitted what he did was wrong
and that this was an accident and he
said that the media just wouldn't let it
drop but there was one headline today
that was like he admits that no it's
everywhere
so insane and if you look at the full
quote he's like i admitted this a long
time look at this look at that a long
time ago yeah ap alex jones concedes
sandy hook attack was 100 real yo he
said that like seven years ago yeah he
conceded it a long time ago it's not
it's not present tense he said he had
used to have so many documents in front
of him and he'd read things and then one
night or and he went on this tirade
about sandy hook that he'd got some
information that was bad information he
didn't vet it and it changed his life
well this is what he told me he said
ever since he's been just
on the evidence he will go deep into
evidence now he doesn't shout stuff out
as much as he used to that fair fare but
i'm not going to cut alex
i'm not going to let him off the hook on
this one there were other people at
infowars that were telling him to stop
and i i had heard this
before the trial started like it was
last year there were people because
we've had alex on the show we've had
other people work with them and they
were like they were telling us people
were telling alex like bro chill on this
stuff you can't do this you can't defame
private citizens like this
apparently it's come out in the trial
they showed emails where staffers and
infowars were were complaining being
like what are you doing even when it
came to the covet stuff people were
getting mad saying like you're you're
saying too much you know
false stuff
so i'll say it outright you you i am i i
think defamation is wrong
alex jones wanted to go on his show and
and and say things that that weren't
true or or you know to to a certain
degree
i think he's got to be held accountable
however i think what's going on right
now is anything but that
i mean i feel like the lawyer was super
smarmy it was just like dude i could not
stand listen to the man because he was
like
alex
and i'm like shut up dude just ask a
question
like i got to tell you this if i'm sick
if i'm sitting listening to a lawyer i'm
telling you i think alex jones was wrong
in this and i think he owes the family
something then their lawyer comes out
and he goes mr jones um you said this
right do you know what perjury is mr
jones and i'm just like wow i really
hate this guy and want alex to win now
cause like he's so awful it's like alex
is up there coughing was he like the
written house prosecutor remember that
guy oh yeah yeah it's just yeah that guy
that guy was annoying except he gave us
the best legal quote of all time don't
get brazen with me
i think
these stories that i heard
that you hear about in the news people
showing up to their houses and stuff
it's horrifying
and there were people that worked with
alex that were telling him like back off
and he he went
full steam or i should say he went steam
enough
that he should have done it now they're
saying they want 150 million dollars
over it and i'm like this is where it's
getting crazy
it doesn't seem like he's getting he's
getting a fair hearing like he didn't
even have he wasn't even granted a jury
trial over this they went straight to uh
uh the damages hearing
it's it's totally insane it absolutely
is so
you know look man the most annoying
thing is they're they they do these
really dirty games
and what blows my mind is it just works
on on on dumb people
so so one thing they're doing is
alex so uh i don't want to use alex
jones a specific example i'll give you a
general example someone will say
something like
do you have i gave the example to ian i
was like ian you have a rock in front of
you this one here is is that rock blue
no
you are testifying right now that there
there is that that is not a blue rock
correct yes okay now hand that rock over
to us
then we'll go ah there it is there is
blue ladies and gentlemen of the jury
the rock blue right there
did you testify this rock was not blue
mr crossland yes and and clearly we can
see there is blue here do you know what
perjury is mr crossland uh
that's what they're doing that's what
they're doing the annoying thing is it's
like
dude
stupid people will fall for that and
it's really annoying if someone says
do you have x and you go
usually you say something like to the
best of my recollection i don't think so
i don't think i have that now i'm not
saying alex is perfect on this one i'm
not here to defend everything he said or
done i'm saying it's really annoying
when it's like
perjury almost never happens perjury
charges because it's impossible to prove
someone's memory is perfect and they
intended to lie yeah like james clapper
when he said they weren't wittingly
spying on the american citizens
well what's the word wittingly he did
say we weren't wittingly doing it so
they were unwittingly spying as
basically what it came down to so
perjury in this in this instance they
said to alex
uh you testified you didn't have emails
pertaining to sandy hook and he was like
i
i may have been mistaken i don't know i
gave you my phone i gave you my emails
right and then they're just like did you
testify you did not and they want him to
say yes without any kind of nuance or
context
then he says do you know what perjury is
mr jones it's like
to taint the jury into believing that
perjury was committed when he will never
be charged for perjury because the
reality is
he probably just didn't know
it's crazy to me that you know we get
thousands of emails per day across the
board thousands you think i know what's
in there yeah so what they'll do is
they'll say do you have emails and i'll
say i don't know and they'll be like
okay well like you're saying you're
unfamiliar with yes and then they'll
probably be like boom there it is we
have it in your database you had it and
it's like dude i don't read those things
right i mean how many unread email
messages do you have i think mine are in
the
many thousands upon thousands of unread
easily well i just i just mark
everything as red every day just
like ignore it i don't do that well
i just you have a company right so
there's so many email servers that could
be like you don't know what's going on
with your own company tim pool that's
crazy like it's just an impossible
standard i think alex i mean i wonder
sometimes with the way the prosecution
is proceeding as if they're just trying
to get him to feel so irritated he has
some outbursts on the stand that can
feed a media cycle for a little while i
mean in some ways it just seems like
they're trying to get under his skin
they're just trying to destroy
alex jones is a huge arsenal for donald
trump it's a victory and so they're
trying to just go after him in any way
possible to make sure that anybody who's
not
absolutely in politics won't listen to
the man now look
alex is a lot of crazy crazy stuff the
reason we have an alex jones was right
jar is because he says a lot of crazy
stuff so when he's right you put the
money in the jar that's that's the gag
when he went on rogan and talked about
like what is it fourth dimensional fifth
dimensional beings and like 5g cell
towers and animal human hybrids i'm like
okay it's it's it's all crazy
you know what i mean but there's a lot
of things he's talked about like epstein
for instance that he's been right about
and chimeras they are real i mean yeah
that's the thing it's like he says
things in ways often where you think
he's nuts and then you realize it's true
like we had him on the show and he was
like we're all eating cloned beef and i
was like what and he's like yeah we're
closing cows in the meat and i'm like no
we aren't that's crazy and i pulled it
up i'm like oh it's
actually true yeah like we show the
sources saying we we do cloned cloned
beef i thought that they already got
alex in a trial for a sandy hook
defamation yeah i thought this didn't we
already see this three years ago or two
years ago but it wasn't uh i don't know
the full
is this civil
well it's all civil that's the other
thing too the left thinks there's
criminal defamation charges i'm like
we're talking defamation's a civil civil
war i also i don't think anyone should
ever answer yes or no questions
oh i agree it's a manipulation every
ever worthwhile i remember getting into
a fight with someone once and they were
yes or no yes or no i was like i told
i'm not even going to agree with the
premise of your stupid question yeah no
one's you never have to answer a
question with someone else wants you to
no that's ridiculous and you never
should the other thing too is if someone
says like you know ian do you have a
blue rock you say to the best of my
understanding i don't believe so
as opposed to no right
because then they're back you said no
you you said no you it's like well i
said to the best of my understanding i
must have been wrong or why do you want
to know what color my rock is you look
at it yeah i don't know that's why i
want a doctor my green could be your
blue when your doctor asks a question
like do you have wasps under your
armpits you say not that i know of
you don't say no because he might be a
magician and have like a wasp up his
sleeve or maybe he's just coming out of
your house he's like well then once he
just didn't know and then there's no way
here it is
doctor says you you're experiencing
wasps under your armpits
anybody who knows that reference will
anyone who understands that reference
will earn a prize no i i don't i happen
to have marshall mcluhan right now
i'm willing to bet a bunch of people and
some people in the chat will totally
understand that reference
we'll see though adrian curry i love
libby
oh i love you too adrian thanks that was
nice that's very sweet i wanna you know
what i was thinking with alex jones
this trial is almost meaningless i feel
like alex could just go on the stand
right now and just be like i'm sorry
that it happened
uh i own up to it it shouldn't have
happened i apologize uh i hope for
forgiveness and i'd love to try and do
what i can and let me know what you
think is is deserving of the families
and we'll do what we can to help them
out did he have the option to settle out
of court well i'm just saying if he did
that
no matter what he does he is still alex
jones and they can never stop this man
yeah like there's literally nothing you
can do worst case scenario they would
bankrupt him make him
close infowars is that what it is they
can't do that that's not possible so
they just bankrupt and then you just
start making money again right so so
here what they could do is you know alex
said anything over 2 million would
destroy the company
considering he got de-platformed it's
entirely possible but i almost don't
know if i believe it
because he's syndicated in other places
and there's other ways that infowars
makes money and i really doubt that his
revenue was two million dollars
so
we'll see i also bet alex has been
planning for this
knowing that they were going to come
after him for large sums of money he's
probably shuffled a bit of his wealth
into areas that protect it i hope so
give it to your kids give it to your
kids
give it to uh you know you can't just
give it to them it's taxed but you can
do transfers that shield it from you
know lost put it into like living
trust yeah trusts are fantastic yeah
it's there's tons of things but i'm just
saying like
even if they were to get the 150 million
what happens tomorrow he goes back in he
does his show
now they might force liquidate his asses
or something but all the man needs is a
cell phone and they what are they gonna
do like we're taking your phone now from
you it's like you can't phone costs 20
bucks do you think they just want to be
able to say like he was convicted of
defamation alex jones who was convicted
of defamation and be able to have that
be the sound bite and sort of his
official moniker for a little while so
like again not that they could
necessarily pull it off but to trash his
credibility and try and purge people who
does that i mean i don't think it would
do anything but maybe they feel like if
they can um
rock the boat on alex jones's supporters
they can gain some sort of influence
over a popular narrative and culture
i don't know probably it's a
short-sighted goal but it might be
because i don't other than that they
just want the money but i mean what you
can't get blood out of a stone 150
million if he only has 2 million revenue
like
well i will say
i think alex jones likely has
more money than
he's letting on but i also think
the other side in this is not playing
fair
at all it's the the process is the
punishment kind of thing right they're
just raking them through it
yeah so like one of the things he said
was this is what they do this how they
get you he said he doesn't do email he
doesn't have email and then they were
like here's a text showing you sending
an email and he was like oh that's like
a personal thing dictated to my
assistant and they're like ah but you
said you didn't have email and it's like
dude oh are you serious yeah like if
someone's if you're like i don't have an
email account but like one time you
might have sent one or two that's just
then they they argue is perjury and all
that stuff and i'm just like i'm so
annoyed by it because if you if anyone
who's sane and rational looks the nuance
outright would just be like yeah hey
screw this one up you know these
families suffered enough let's sort this
one out instead you've got
the opposing lawyer is like one of the
worst people i've ever heard speak
and then everyone's just flinging crap
at each other and i'm like nobody looks
good here thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there